when you click on a wild ride clips
channel video you know you're going to
get something juicy and when you buy
products from native you know you're
going to get something good thanks to
native for bringing you this hot juicy
clip she didn't
let go
until she knew you were gonna be okay
and
then
we had her ashes sitting on the top
shelf
in this closet
we had never talked about like we knew
that
as a family we're kind of not that big
on cemeteries because you're taking up
you know a plot of land that'll never be
usable for anything else
um it it seems and it's creepy
it's just you know the exact reason
steve hates ceremonies it's creepy you
know it's yeah it's it's
counterproductive it's creepy and and
and it's like an eye for an eye makes
the whole world blind
you know burial makes the whole world a
cemetery so we knew we were gonna have
her
we knew we were gonna have a cremated
but we didn't know what to i didn't know
what to do with it with these ashes like
we didn't have like a vault or anything
she didn't have a particular place that
she loved
we didn't have
you know we've moved around so much
um growing up that it wasn't like we had
a really special place on the globe
where you could like put a push pin
and that was like our place
and so dad like like it had been like a
number of years the mom's ashes were
just in this closet and
our dad goes to uh
uh uh some psychic and i don't know
where the psychic says hey
your ex-wife
uh needs to be
set free or released or something it's
like her ashes like being in the club
like her solar spirit is stunned it's
closure and that was just like kind of
good major goose pumps just saying that
like that's pretty specific you know
like the ash is like to refer to the
ashes so
in december of 2011 cindy and i finally
by then you had started surfing
no no no no and
when when i i i pissed somebody off
really badly when i was in rehab in
2008
i like uh it was one there was an older
guy
and we were in some group and i was like
you know
i just said for some reason in this
career i said i never want to snort
anything
again in my life
except maybe a line of my mom's ashes
that i'm just being like what i don't
even know what the [ __ ] and this this
old guy was like very offended by that
well
yeah i never actually meant to snort my
mom's ashes but in december of 2011
cindy and i had like paid for like a a
charter a charter boat i needed to
scatter her at sea yeah and it just so
happened that when a gust of wind well
yeah it was choppy seeds it was windy as
hell i got in the back of the on the bed
like the bow of the boat and and throw
the ashes and the wind
[ __ ] blows her ashes into my face and
i was like like just happened and and
then i just started laughing i was like
i just snorted my mom's lashes
would have gotten a kick out of that
yeah i mean it was sort of like a
everybody likes the ocean
no matter where we are you know it's a
place that we
find spiritual um and and right steve
now surfs on regularly
so this was december of 2011. i snorted
her ashes like by accident
we come back and it was just so choppy
and such a nightmare
honestly and we got back we drove
separately and we also
burned her um journals from aaa
inventory and stuff like um just kind of
let her
all of that stuff go in a bonfire and
this gnarly picture she had of her mom
all drunk and remember yeah just um but
as we we got back to the dock you know
the the um parking lot where we went on
this charter boat i'm sure we were in
separate cars and we drove you know back
back home as we pulled away
the only time
in my life that i can ever remember
seeing
uh
two
completely distinctly separate rainbows
like just so pronounced
and and like we drove from scattering
our ashes and i was just like looking at
these
they were huge and they were not saying
that one double rainbow you're saying a
rainbow here and then over there that's
another rainbow
like
yeah i mean they were so distinctly
separate yeah it's amazing and i i like
it
it was very impactful to me i thought
wow like
like that's a one rainbow for me and
it's one rainbow for cindy
and um
it and it just so happened that the very
next month january of
2012 i uh you know i went on tour to
hawaii and like that someone's like dude
you want to go surfing i'm like dude the
last thing i want to do is go surfing
but they just i was like oh all right
and i had so much fun i had so i caught
the bug and then i caught the big net
now so we'd scatter mom in the ocean and
then from that point on
all i wanted to do was be in the ocean i
just fell in love with surfing i served
all the time and whenever i was in the
ocean and saw a rainbow
like hey ma big moment yeah yeah that
was always like a big thing that's cool
so rainbow rainbows are my deal if you
go to nativedeodorant.com
and use the promo code stevo you get 20
off your first order and like i said man
this company they're good people they do
the right thing they don't harm animals
they only use quality ingredients that
are good for you there's no aluminum
i just love them and i want you to
support them i want you to smell good
and feel good so one more time go to
nativedeodorant.com
and use the promo code stevo for 20 off
your order
and to feel good about smelling good and
supporting good people